e
uh welcome I'm opening the meeting on
the special committee um for Department
of Children family children Youth and
Family
we have um some of our members in
attendance today we don't have a full
full desk but that's all right um and we
have a very important person in the
audience as well so welcome welcome
representative kushman um so I'm GNA
open it up and I'm going to read the
charges of our committee um and then
we're going to have uh just a little bit
of an oversight of where we've been as I
do that I will hand out these um
overviews of federal funding um title
for federal funding um just so that
people can have a copy of this this was
Panic so the charge for this committee
said that that this hereby established
special committee on the division for
children youth and families to consider
all matters pertaining to due process
and practices related to DCF the special
committee shall consist of 10 members of
the House who shall conduct hearings and
re receive testimony relative to DCF and
may make recommendations for future
legislation so looking at our history we
heard lots of good testimony regarding
DC we heard from people who had
significant problems with the process
and how it was handled we've reviewed
information we've reviewed the way that
the depart the division has set up um
and as we mve through that quite frankly
we've realized that it's a strange
combination of laws rules and policies
that can be little hard to follow from
time to
time we also may make recommendations
for future legislation and reviewing the
lsrs I found that there are three that
are relative to um department of
children youth the division of children
youth and families the first is LSL LSR
35 that I've filed to establish as its
own state agency a department for
children youth and families um I filed
that one I'm still working on the
language is something that I can share
with all of you when I have it um but
it's my view that that'll provide
greater oversight and greater
transparency uh representative Spain has
filed LSR 65 I I'm guessing it's a
refiling although I haven't looked at
the haven't asked him about the text
that's relative to the penalty for
filing false reports and representative
love has filed uh LSR 139 which uh by
the title says that it would require DCF
to notify law enfor enforcement officers
of assaults and and um attempted I
believe attempted assaults on children
assaults on children yes so um with
those I don't think we have the text of
any of those but that does look like
it's some work that's moving forward for
legislation regarding
dcyf um yes what was the number of that
139 thank
you and um with that I know that in mine
including d process has a fundamental
practice within DC the department of DCF
is key to my legislation making sure
that that is respected throughout the
process and um quite frankly having
assaults um fonus assaults on children
actually reported to the police is also
due process because while you may be
dealing with that as a family off Family
issue you shouldn't be able to punch a
child in the face without talking to a
police officer and dealing with those
consequences quite frankly um so the
question would be if anybody else here
is drafting legislation that they would
discuss okay oh yes yes if you put that
on um you can ask a question I did have
a question um last term or last year uh
representative Hull had presented a same
uh similar legislation to yours as far
as DCF pulling away from DHHS is it
going along in that same mindset is is
it does it read the same um thank you
for the question no it does not that
sort of highlights how few statutes
actually refer to the division for
children youth and families in our laws
um which is one of the challenges
regarding oversight that did have an
interesting conversation um where the
Deputy Commissioner and the then acting
uh dcyf director spoke about the various
oversight and
transparency um so they report to the
children's oversight committee monthly
they report to HHS oversight
occasionally um the Office of the child
advocate has oversight um
responsibilities relative to the
children there's the Family Division
Circuit of the circuit court that has an
interaction there's Casa that has
interaction and there's the government
and Council that has
interaction um to me quite frankly
having such a large constellation of
oversight may have some conflicts within
it so I think that moving forward in the
process it would be interesting to see
where those interactions are and if
diffuse oversight is helpful or may
actually lead to different things that
are lost in in the scuel um I think as
far as when you look at good management
at least outside of government you want
to make sure you're not reporting to too
many different um oversight areas um but
we'll we'll be able to look at that and
see and I think that that would be an
important discussion moving forward but
that is what stopped that bill from
moving forward in committee when I
looked at the testimony um that and a
pretty interesting fiscal note so I've
spoken to the legislative budget uh
office as well and um I'm looking to get
a better understanding of the details
surrounding that because filing the same
bill again is not necessar not the most
productive process in my mind unless
it's one where it's clear it's distinct
and it's small um or at least easily
you um and then so I'd like to ask the
members of the committee if any of you
have received specific requests for
legislation from the public to discuss I
know heard about the large big p picture
issues but it's kind of hard to take all
of that and then translate it down to an
action especially when we only have a
few statutes which actually refer to
DCF representative Weber well this isn't
directly responsive to the question
because the answer is no I have not had
anybody in the public uh speak to me
about
DCF um
the concern that I have and and I think
it's it's um always worth discussing
whether and and certainly we've had any
number of discussions in the past about
uh whether D DHHS as a whole is too
large and whether dcyf specifically
ought to um be broken
off um and that has implications both
for the oversight and management side of
things and the fiscal side of things uh
but
here's the thing that I find is always
the nub of this matter and it's why in
in a vacuum I find it really hard to say
oh I'm I'm for that or I'm not for that
I think it's a very good subject for
discussion and I think discussions are
of that kind of issue are always
productive the thing that is terribly
terribly difficult is the
tension
between on the one hand the rights of
parents which we want to protect and on
the other hand the rights of children
which we want to protect and The Clash
of two fundamental constitutional rights
is
always a difficult area and it's a
difficult area to get it right because
it's easy to take one case and
say that was wrong because it was and
it's clear to all of us that something
happened that was
wrong taking that and codifying it in a
way that both prevents similar action
but does not impinge on other
fundamental act rights or make things
more difficult in some other area that
we didn't even imagine is the challenge
that we have and that's why I am um you
know loath to think about anywhere that
anything that we could recommend as a
committee from what I have heard that I
can say
definitively wow this is one thing that
will really help out because the
tensions come at those margins and where
you have fallible human beings trying to
operate
within the scheme all of which is set up
to protect all kinds of different
interests at all kinds of different
levels so
um nothing that I said there is any kind
of conclusion other than that I don't
think that
we I don't think of anything that I
would be comfortable with us as a
committee saying gee we ought to
definitely do that because a lot of what
we heard was individuals who in their
individual
case
um might have an issue but that issue
isue first of all we didn't hear both
sides of the story and secondly uh the
issue um is so specific to that case
that I didn't discern a pattern that I
thought was actionable I have been on
other committees where we did discern
patterns and did recommend uh uh changes
in the statute and so that those
Communications would become more more
easy and simpler and I know there is
also another I will also say that I'm
also on a um uh committee headed by
Senator Ward which is looking at access
to confidential medical records which
does impact this area
because that committee gets tied up in
the issue of well who who who gets to
consent to the release of Records it's
the parent well if the issue is whether
the parent
harmed a child they're not going to say
yes and the other parent may not be
available or may be too frightened so
then you have to get a court order and
how do you streamline that process and
how do you once you've gotten the
records ensure that people can both dcyf
and law enforcement can share them back
and forth because you
can't or in some cases you can but it's
another set of statutes that
are not always understood so uh thank
you representative Weber those are good
points and I think that that's why it's
always challenging to make sure that
we're not responding to a particular
incident with legislation I've found so
many of these scattered throughout our
laws as though we had to do something
about this that then has unforeseen
consequences uh but one of the things
that I did hear is I heard that there
does seem to be um we've heard about
some of the real problem parents the
ones that have made the headlines the
ones um
unfortunately the lost children and the
things that have happened with them so
there's the group on the extreme of
the these the the parents that that
really should have lost their rights to
their children and then on the other
side you have parents that are and
coming back from that towards the middle
you have parents who are very
experienced with these interactions they
know how to handle it they know how to
manage the interactions as they as they
manage the interactions they're able to
perhaps get away with a little bit more
than some parents could and then you
move towards the middle and pass there
and you find a naive parent who hears
that somebody is coming to offer help
and offers up all the information that
you can just like the times of a
grandmother in some neighborhoods that
allow the police to come in and search
for somebody and then they find their
grandson's gun or drugs underneath the
sofa and now Grandma goes to jail and
loses her house because she's on
section8 um and so we need to make sure
that our policies and procedures are
protective of these naive well-meaning
parents and ones who aren't naive
they're they're they understand what's
going on but they don't understand the
entire mechanism of it as well because
if we get to a it's a it's a very
delicate balance it's a very challenging
one that's why it's something that needs
to be dealt with as we move forward and
continue to improve on our processes uh
but I do think that making sure that
processes and policies are clear and
consistent throughout um even if you
take a different approach to somebody on
um this side who thinks it's okay to hit
a child who's strapped into a car seat
and this side who opens up everything
everything and just Bears their soul
whenever somebody comes to the door we
need to figure out some consistency
because I have heard very very
inconsistent treatment from parents and
families throughout the state based on
the perception of the families
perception of their abilities P
perception of their social status and
growing up with a neighbor who was
abused by his parents and his dad was on
a child abuse board I'm very very
cautious about the social proof clearing
somebody but also seeing other families
where it was a parent who was doing
their absolute best and loved their kids
desperately but the state stepped into
those that's our challenge to make sure
that the department is balancing this so
that's why I don't think that we're
ready to talk about any specifics on
these but I one of the major charges is
making recommendations for future
legislation and in my visioning of that
you know we may have something where we
say this is great we're all going to
co-sponsor this um I also might hit the
lottery today so I'm going to leave
everything as a opportunity I'm going to
leave all these possibilities open and I
hope that as we discuss these we can
find things that we can move forward and
agree upon but if not even if we move
forward and say that some members of the
committee thought this is was a good
Avenue to pursue While others had these
concerns that will help also help the
process and if the bill is drafted and
introduced there'll be better
information for the committee that hears
it next term so that we can make sure we
have a more thorough process and we get
through these iterations of public
comment faster so that we can come to a
conclusion and actually help out
families more
um so those are most of the parts that I
wanted to look at I definitely want to
um open it up to the other committee
members I know that representa Panic put
together this um information on title
core funding I can't take credit for
that um
microphone representative Leah kushman
sent that to me so she did all the work
or AI did okay thank you thank
you I do have a question yes where we're
getting one-sided
testimony how do we get DCF to come in
here to testify because we're only
um so part of the challenge is some of
the interactions with the Department
um a ceas and assist letter was not
helpful to cooperation from the
department and there's been no
information from them sense and since
there's no mechanism or process in order
to compel appear appearance before
anybody of the legislature that's
something that has started us off with
one hand tied behind our back so it has
been challenging but I also understand
the depth of importance and emotion and
passion on this and we all perceive the
best that we can at the time as we know
but sometimes we don't know the Ripple
decision so if we move this committee
forward
to another twoyear
session how do we get
DCF to come in otherwise we're still
going to just get a one-sided testimony
question I'd be interested in your
opinions on that and I'm I don't know if
the change of the legislature will
change that or not um all I know is we
can move forward as we can and get the
information that we can if we have a
process in order to have more
information departments that will be
helpful um but that's one of the areas
that we need to determine I do know that
in some other states um there's
information that comes and they do have
an ability to question um but a lot of
that is set up to both chairman
discretion some of the states are set
with a very different Power structure
than we have here in our 400 person
house um so get to be a challenge
representative Weber well I'm just going
to say this straight out um
this committee was set up at the
discretion of the current
speaker at the request of a
member with a very very specific goal
and bent already built into its
charge and when we met the first couple
of
times it was very clear to me that the
view of what due process was in this
committee was going to be very very
different from what I learned about due
process in law school and what I believe
about due process from my reading of the
Constitutions and I think
that a committee that was established in
a
manner that was more open and clear
about the establishment and goals of the
commit
committee and the openness of the
committee
might be more
productive um I can't I can't talk from
anybody other than me but you know it's
been very difficult for me to sit and
listen to lecture after lecture from
people who tell me that unless there is
a jury trial in every single case a
court is illegitimate
I that that doesn't work for me um and
so I think that in many ways
the way the committee was
established was
um
um already started the committee with a
perception that it might not
be a Level Playing Field and you know
that may be rightly or wrongly and it's
certainly just my perception but it I
think we have had many many committees
that have worked very
collaboratively um very openly and with
an enormous amount of cooperation of
everybody involved and I think that
moving on to a different sort of forum
where that could happen again because it
is happening in all the other committees
that deal with this subject it's just
this one so um I think that that is part
of the
problem I would say that some of the
other committees also do seem to have
people show up with one particular
mindset and so it does not those those
committees even if there may not be as
much perceived descent with what's
happening in the state doesn't mean that
there aren't people that are still
concerned with it but they don't feel
that it'll be a valid forum for them to
express their views because when there's
already a great alignment between people
who are providing oversight to an agency
with the agency's actions um it feels it
feels ra almost sometimes even hostile
to come and speak to a committee like
that um so we are hearing testimony that
probably that didn't really come to any
others because they didn't feel that it
was a committee that wanted to listen to
those statements and while we have been
more one-sided because a variety of
issues we've heard very important very
important testimony because not
everybody comes and shares this
information and we do need to look to
all of these different issues and we
need to understand that while in this
committee we're seeing more of one side
of this there's other committees that
are also seeing more of the department
side that doesn't help us to have the
department show up to these particular
meetings but it does help to the greater
discourse around the area representative
love thanks for taking my I guess it's
not a question but my my uh my
information uh you asked if any of us
any of us have been contacted by anyone
in the public and and I have I uh I was
contacted by a grandmother who had uh
her her daughter had four
children and um the father of the of
three of the children uh came back into
their life and started abusing everybody
in the house and she went to get a um a
restraining order and the judge decided
that they should go to to DCF for
investigation well they uh they took the
three older ones and left her with the
most vulnerable and adopted them out to
a family in
Florida um the grandmother was supposed
to be able to have contact with them she
hasn't had contact with them for quite a
while close to a year now uh they have
no idea where the kids are uh then
nobody will tell them um and I see here
the uh the uh adoption it's a assistant
grants it it it kind of really reeks of
the state is taking money
uh for for lack of a better word
stealing kids um you know I've I've
talked to to people that know the the
the mother uh and she's not a bad mother
the kids are always clean and wellfed
and all that uh they are special needs
too and um you know boy it just reeks of
something's really wrong here and um you
know nobody says anything and they pick
on people that have no money it seems we
we had one woman come in here and talked
about her her child uh being taken right
off his bicycle okay another poor mother
didn't have much money um you know I I
one second representative love just
saying that you're picking on someone's
kind of ascribing some motive to it so
if you could just tone that conversation
um you know but uh you know this this
grandmother was in tears and uh you know
please do something and um you know like
I said she's uh they took the they they
left her with the most they left the the
mother with the most vulnerable you know
the child was three I think at the time
and uh and took the older ones you know
something isn't right there I just don't
you know the the policies the DC DCF
policies are all over the place you know
that they use it here they don't use it
over here they you know um we we had one
one guy come in here and he he said a a
statement that I heard myself 20 over 20
years ago okay no broken bones no
hospitalization risen much we can do
when he said that yeah you know the
anger came back my my daughter had had
the hell beit out of her by her mother
okay and that's what I got you know
teachers turned her in doctors turned
her in I was just an Angry Dad okay they
wouldn't do anything okay the the dcyf
policies stink you know if if they if
they're going to use them if they're
going to apply them uniformly for
everybody fine but they don't and look
let's find out why thank you
representative love I think that the
equal application of the policies is
absolutely critical MH thank you
representa panic thank you um
chairman we're only hearing
one um side of the
coin and it's a very emotionally charged
side and it's so easy for all of us to
get swept up into it because it's
we all care about children that's why
we're here all
right
my concern
is how do we get what steps are we
legally allowed to take to bring
DCF in here because I'm sure they have
their side of the story and once we hear
it all this might make more sense to to
us all right I'm getting the feeling
we're getting a very
unbalanced uh
testimony I but I'm we're not hearing
the other side of why they did what they
did and we have to be able to be able to
ask them those questions can and and I'm
not
saying I'm not saying your side of the
story isn't correct I'm just trying to
find out what was the logic behind
DCF for doing what they're doing and
that would help us be able to see what
we can do to fix things all right
because that that's the intentions here
can we subpoena a DCF to come
in um there is a POS a potential to do
that with the full vote of the house but
without any penalties for The subpoena
it's um I I feel like that's one of the
times when I tell my my kids that
there's going to be a consequence that I
can't back up um and so I'm concerned
that requesting a subina that's not
complied with actually weakens the
position of the legislature but I do
believe that you brought up a very
important point right now we are hearing
a lot from the parents you know some
parents by the time they had children
and had the interactions weren't all
even all that many years removed from
being a child them themselves so the
idea of flipping from one side you're
fully protected you're a few years later
you're a child who's been vulnerable and
now you're a parent but now you're not
seen you know that empathy seems to go
one way more than it goes two ways the
DCF has had every opportunity and every
invitation to come and speak to us they
have the ability to come and share their
side of the story they can't speak to
specific cases um a lot of that is
limited um we actually until recently
some of the cases even if you were the
parent you couldn't disclose so there's
been part of the issue too is that there
had sort of been a um little privacy
bubble secrecy bubble around proceedings
that had happened within DCF and that
may or may not have led to sort of
policies being applied in one way in
some situations and another way in
another because we can't know because
parents were charged with potential
violations for speaking about their
cases
um so there needs to my concern is that
with the diffuse oversight there are
some challenges there but I don't know
that that's something that we can look
can change how that oversight is done if
anybody wants to look at one of those
the particular charges that may actually
be a very helpful thing for us to look
and see specifically which oversight the
children's oversight committee has I
know representative long um has been on
that for a long time um and
understanding what they do makes sense
but the parents also need to have their
voices heard everybody that I see here
listed is looking and representing the
side of the children um which is
critical because they're vulnerable but
the parents also can be vulnerable
representative Walmer sorry
representative Weber I'm sorry okay I
used to say June and July
interchangeably on the trading floor and
that's not good with
options
um it I just wanted a point of
clarification because
I don't know of a case in which parents
were prevented from speaking should they
choose to do so about their
DCF issues there are court
orders refusing that in the context of a
divorce and that's where we have
particularly had problems here in the
legislature when one parent has come and
said this this this and this and then
somebody showed up with a court order
that says everything you just heard was
protected and and um under a
non-disclosure order so I just I just
wanted to
uh thank you I'm sure you probably
blocked from your memory as much as I
have our marathon session um two terms
ago when we were potentially going to
have to clean the lob ourselves because
we were staying so late on a deadline um
there was amend an amendment within
there which um removed some of the
penalties for parents speaking about
their cases in front of dcyf that one
was not related to divorce plans um and
at this point my specific Recollections
are a bit hazy but um that sort of
Omnibus well I will defer that we had
had did didn't include that and um
listening to those changes it's just
making sure that we can also make sure
that the parents are heard and that they
are also supported in the process
because if our end goal is strong
families uh we can support both sides
and hopefully have stronger families
without only supporting one
side but the devil's in the details and
how do we do
that uh so to let you know what I think
that our next meeting should entail I
will be presenting an overview of the
structure of dcyf including laws rules
and policies and sort of how they
interact an overview of the
organizational structure um hopefully
I'll have some more information on
legislation to share and if there's
anybody else with specific legislative
language we can speak about that um but
I just want to make sure that we sort of
put a pin in how dcyf looks at this
point and understands that so um I don't
know if any other other committee
members um have something to say at this
point I was going to then see if anybody
who's um joined us today wanted to
address us with any information
representative
who given that we are very late in the
legislative session that this will be a
lame duck um legislature starting in
less than three
weeks I am wondering what the purpose is
is of starting with an overview
of that which we perhaps might ought to
have had an overview of in the very
beginning but why are we doing it now
because this committee will end in
December with the new legislature yes um
I was not looking to give a very
intricate and detailed overview but to
present the information of the breakdown
the structures and sort of how they
interact at a high level 30,000 foot um
so that we could look at it in 5 to 10
minutes to understand at least which
pieces go where in the 24 piece puzzle
not the 2400 piece puzzle um this is one
of the areas where understanding what is
included within
DCF and how they're overseen is helpful
to understand whether moving to um a
stand more Standalone process even if it
is a more distinct and legislatively
outlined um subunit of DHHS because
right now there is very very L very
little
legislation um that outlines the
specifics most of it is up to the
discretion of the commissioner um most
of the Department of Health and Human
Services is where the power is given to
the commissioner to create uh whatever
is necessary in order to fulfill their
duties and um my view is that by
outlining that more distinctly in
legislation would help us to provide
greater o oversight because if we have
not created the laws surrounding it it's
hard for the legislature to provide
oversight you may disagree with me but I
won't no I'm just trying to I'm just
trying to clarify because of course
anybody has the right to introduce any
legislation they want to and I think
that that is good and helpful and and
Prov thought-provoking which is very
useful um
and what I am asking
is a clarification now because you said
you wanted to present an overview of how
dcyf works works and then I heard you
saying with an eye to new
legislation
and again I'm I'm wondering at this
point so to clarify that the new
legislation would be separate because
one of our main charges is to um provide
input on future legislation and so I
would give the small short summary
usually when I'm speak speaking not in
the meeting I try and keep things short
um which would be my intention here
because if I talk too long long I bore
myself and I know that most people get
so so by doing that and trying to
understand and quite frankly it is such
a nebulous division that it's been
difficult for me to really understand
that structure and given the work that
I've done in my past the things that
I've done I feel that if I have trouble
understanding that structure and how it
interacts with each other um I either
need to be able to figure figure out how
to explain it succinctly or we have
larger problems and I think I've reached
the point where I may be able to get
those interactions and understand them
better so if you feel that I'm making
you part of my thought on exercise I
apologize but uh I I will share the
information with everybody ahead of time
I I'm I'm just not sure why this
committee needs to do that if we're not
looking at the legislation we're only
looking at the structure and we are
within 3 weeks of the end
of you
know not three weeks at the end of our
tenure because of course we all go
through to the beginning of December but
it just seems to me to
be
um the wrong exercise at the wrong
time thank you I'll be the hopefully the
legislation will be drafted to be able
to share and have that information by
the time that we come to meet
representative panic
thank you chairman Lian my understanding
is though even though December ends this
legislative year I was
told
by certain people uh who
are um so with that I I think I was just
in jel car this morning so I think I'll
hop onto that continuity issue uh so on
gel car The Joint legislative committee
on administrative rules um the speaker
will need to appoint the new Jael before
the December Jael car meeting or else
the December Jael car meeting will not
be able to happen there is nothing that
by default carries over from term to
term so it will require a renaming of
members if this committee were to
continue in his exact same form um with
the members who are continuing because I
know representative long will well
there's a good chance that he'll be
Senator long um by then um or citizen
long one or the other um but he won't be
able to be on this committee as a house
committee so even if we were to continue
on it still would require the action by
the speaker to do that while the speaker
is lining up a number of other things so
even if it continues there's probably
going to be a bit of a void before we're
to reconstitute thank you for the
clarification you're welcome I'm still
you and I will make one promise to you
representative Weber that if I don't
think that that discussion is going to
to get us anywhere fruitful it will not
be long it will be short and we'll make
sure that we are not just uh sitting
here and having mental gymnastics that
point and with that um would anybody
like to address the
committee you want to come up and state
your name for me and then I'll have you
fill out a p i I'll have you write it
down make sure that we have the spelling
correct
okay um so sorry and just before you
start there's a number of us that do
have other commitments later on so
hopefully this doesn't mean that we'll
be cutting anything short if we as long
as we keep it to a shorter presentation
that we can concentrate on I'll do my
best be great thank you U my name is
grelli Glenn I'm um I'm a mother um I am
homeless currently at the moment my
children were removed from me by DCF um
a year ago September
18th for reason because I was homeless
um I brought I brought my experte that
was you know that they give to the court
in order to be able to for for them to
remove the custody of my children
and um we know that the law says that in
order for them to remove your children
them children must be in imminent at
risk or in imminent danger and
um I'm just going to read you a piece of
a uh uh of what they submitted to the
court that was signed off by the judge
as reason to remove my children even
though the law itself says that um
children shouldn't that they if if it's
strictly financial reasons it's not
that's not a way that they can't find
you to be neglectful if those are the
only um
circumstances so this is her she did the
um Elizabeth Barney DCF Manchester
District office who under oath submitted
this to the court and um it says that
the division has received reports of
concerns for Miss Glenn's homelessness
with the minor children since July of
this year although Miss Glenn has been
difficult to engage since July the
division was very recently able to
confirm that Miss Glenn and the children
had been staying at lilian's Motel in
nashwa on September 15th the division
received a call from Heather Moren from
Manchester City Welfare stating Miss
Glenn was not eligible for services due
to monies that were unaccounted for and
placed on a 14-day suspension Miss Glenn
was refusing to leave Manchester City
Welfare stating that she was going to
camp on the lawn outside of City Welfare
with her two children supervisor Megan
bivan spoke with Miss Glenn who was
unable to identify a place for her and
her children to stay due to miss Glenn
being disorderly at City Welfare the
Manchester police was Department was
contacted the Manchester police was able
to arrange shelter for Miss Glenn
through families in transition through
the week through the weekend today
September 18th Miss Glenn returned to
Manchester City Welfare but was informed
that she was still not eligible for
shelter nor that families in transition
have any open beds for her and her
children Manchester police was contacted
again in Manchester City Welfare due to
miss Glenn's escalating behavior and
Miss Glenn was arrested for resisting
arrest and disorderly conduct cpsw
Elizabeth Barney was able to speak with
Miss Glenn prior to her arrest and Miss
Glenn was again unable to identify a
place for her and her children to stay
thus leaving the children without
appropriate shelter for the evening
based on the foregoing there is
reasonable cause to believe that the
children are in circumstances or
surroundings that present an imminent
risk to his or her health life or life
that necessitate immediate out of home
placement the children are without
proper parental care or control or or
necessary control for their physical
mental or emotional health and their
health is very likely to suffer serious
impairment based on the foregoing there
is reasonable cause to believe that the
continuation in the home is contrary to
the welfare of the above referenced
children expart relief is the only
relief available for the division now
the part that she left out was that
while I was arrest when I was arrested
my children were at school and I called
my 24y old son to pick the children up
from school when my son got to my
youngest son School DCF was on the phone
with the school
now they have no business and no reason
to be on the phone with my children's
school because just because I got
arrested parents get arrested all the
time and I was supposed to be presumed
innocent until proven guilty so why was
she on the phone with with with the
school because she she thought that I
wasn't that no one was going to be there
to pick up my children from school that
I didn't make arrangements or whatever
the case may be she assumed that so my
son shows up at the school she's on the
phone she asks him what if the kids were
going to are going to be with him for
the evening if they have somewhere to
stay my son has his own apartment have
two older children one's 29 and one's 24
they both have their own
Apartments um she he said yes they're
going to be staying with him she asked
for his address he reluctantly he has
passed because this is not my first time
dealing with DCF so he has his own
experiences with DCF now and he's an
adult now so he reluctantly he didn't
really want to but he reluctantly gave
her his address and so that where the
children would be nonetheless right
within that time they were finding their
ex parte and then she and then she when
I called her to ask her why she was on
the phone with my children's school she
was claiming that she couldn't hear me
and she was going to call me back and
when she called me back is when she gave
told me that um they F an exte and I
needed to I needed to hand over my
children now I don't hear anything that
I've read to y'all to you guys that is
fitting under the law of imminent danger
uh uh because being arrested is not is
not they were at school so they weren't
there and when they were we there the
police found somewhere for us to go and
that's not that's not enough that's not
it doesn't show imminent danger that I'm
going to that I didn't tell them where
I'm going to be sleeping at I don't have
an obligation to tell them where I'm
where I'm going to be or where I'm
sleeping that's none of their business
when when they first contacted me in
July I specifically said that to them
because like I said I have experiences
with them I know how they get down so um
I I record my conversations with them um
I let everybody know that I deal with
that no one's going to be able to say
anything about me that's not true
because that's what I've experienced in
the past and simply because I don't have
a title or I don't work for some agency
whatever I say doesn't matter I'm not
believed anywhere any anywhere or
anytime I have not been believed
whatever they say the the things that
they write in their reports that they
they manipulate that they turn into make
and make it seem like the people the
parents are the most horrible parents in
the world that's not how it really is
and and the fact that we are that they
they are doing this under the guise of
the best interest of the children is is
is
outlandish because there is no way that
anybody going to tell me to my face that
what they have done to my children
removed my children from me I've not
seen my children since March I'm not
barely I'm able I don't speak to my
seven-year-old my youngest child seveny
old now I don't speak with him they they
I'm supposed they have their own
protocols they have all those protocols
that they're supposed to follow that the
parents are supposed to be they supposed
to honor the voice of the parents
they're supposed to be included in all
the decisions that are being made with
the children all of those things and
they are not doing any of those things
and just because I have an attitude
doesn't mean that they don't have to
that they don't have to inform me of
these things and it and what what what's
really contradictory about my case is
that she came to my hotel room 4 days
before they filed the expart and told me
that they were closing my case
that's what she said to me at my door
that they were closing my case not that
not like she wrote in her report they
were going to close my case if I
maintain having somewhere to stay no
that's not what you said because you
wouldn't how would you even do that how
would you even close the case as long as
I maintain somewhere to stay you would
still have to have the case open to
review or whatever so uh how do you how
do you go from closing the closing the
case and then four days later f the next
part to remove my children so either all
of these things that you wrote about me
in this in this after David under the
pains and penalties of perjury are true
and you didn't do your job the first
time by coming to my hotel room and
closing my case or you didn't do your
job the second time by helping me and
assisting me with whatever you're
supposed to do besides removing my
children I asked them very clearly how
are you going to help me I'm homeless
that's the problem that's the reports
you got right you got reports of
homelessness so how are you going to
assist me do you have a shelter for us
do you have an apartment for us do you
have some money for us what resources do
you have are you going to put me on some
list I said all of those things to her
on the phone in
July she had nothing to
offer there was a police uh um I have a
letter from the chief of police from
Greenland who who wrote who wrote a
letter stating that she when uh because
I had a dealing with another shelter
because I got there late they wouldn't
accept me it was like an hour and a half
away so they wouldn't accept me and my
children so I had to again I'm on
survival mode here how what else am I
supposed to do so I get a little hyped
up these people are doing things they're
not supposed to do and obviously here
comes the police but we were in her at
her station all day long called every
possible every place possible she called
DCF DCF supposed to help people with the
you know with these situations so so we
so people think and they told her there
was nothing that she could do for me she
spoke directly to Elizabeth Berney
there's nothing that they can do for me
so why are you involved then you know
what my situation is City Welfare the
the you went you signed on and said that
you made reasonable efforts because in
order to remove your children you got to
make reasonable efforts and you little
check mark and said you made reasonable
efforts to prevent the removal of my
children what were those reasonable
efforts that you made till this day I
have not gotten any answers of that they
consider calling City welfare and
finding out all my business and how much
money I got how much money I make and
this and that reasonable effort that's
what they consider to be reasonable
effort to prevent the remov of my
children and the last thing I want um
another thing is I I wanted to say is uh
since being in my in in since my
children being in in custody my
14-year-old son has reactive attachment
dis
water now what that is is the fear of
being left being abandoned always being
on edge wondering
anxious and this happening is
like because at the point when they took
my when they took my children we had we
had worked really hard my son got
suspended you know periodically from
school and he had to go self-contained
classrooms and all the whatever we work
but I advocated for my son all the way
through and we had gotten to right
before DCF interrupted Our Lives to
where the best we were at the best point
he had ever been the school like you
know he everybody was proud of him he
had come such a long way and we had
worked so hard to get him to that point
and then DCF comes and takes my child
and he gets suspended 15 times from
school just last year alone after they
took
him he hasn't been suspended 15 times in
his whole life never mind in a year so
all the work that we did all those years
that I worked and that we worked hard to
get him to the point that we where he
was and they they undid all of that and
caused more damage on top of that and
that's not okay because this is supposed
to be in the best interest of my
children and now my son is being
Warehouse like that article from the
Associated Press there because he was in
a foster home with his brother and um
the foster home didn't feel like they
wanted him there anymore because they
thought that he was going to act out or
whatever so they sent my son to the
hospital in an ambulance by himself 14
years old to have a psychological
evaluation he gets to the hospital has
the whatever he's there for 24 hours by
himself I have Tex from him going back
and forth to the clinician who you know
okayed him going there um asking when
what you know when when can I go I'm
sorry blah blah blah whatever whatever
14 years old by himself over 24 hours if
I would have sent my son to the hospital
in an ambulance by himself at 14 years
old what do you think DCF would have
done so why is it okay for them to do
these things and get away with it like
it's all right I have a recording right
here of my that my son recorded that my
son recorded because he knows how I how
I am he knows what I do in the way that
I am I've been like this because this
has been my life experience
and he recorded on his own and the
supervisor of DCF on this recording
tells my son that they don't want him
because the Foster person that where my
youngest son was where they were
together she didn't want to keep him no
more that's why they sent him to the
hospital to have the
evaluation and she tells him we don't
have anywhere to put you we don't have
he has two older brothers who have their
own apartment we don't have anywhere to
put you and and they don't want you she
says and they don't want you and it's
right here on the recording so you guys
can get DCF Strat of the story and you
guys can get charges for being illegally
reported but as far as I'm concerned
when these people are in the official
capacity of their duties these are their
state actors these are State people
working on in an official capacity and
and when it's and what's at stake here
is children's best actual best interest
Miss Glenn yes I am so sorry for you and
your children for the experience that
you've gone through in this this sounds
like it's been incredibly difficult for
you especially for your son who was
building working on building his
relationships and you know personally I
I I wasn't part of any of that but I'm
really really sorry that this all
happened to you um looking at it and
just trying to understand from us I I
understand why you have a mistrust um it
seems like it developed over time and
didn't want to tell them where you where
you were were and where where you were
going to be keeping your children um I'm
going to go ahead and assume that you
had a nice warm place with the roof over
it it was dry but because even if I did
it my children always did because their
brothers you know submitted affidavit to
say that yes and um so with all all that
but it's looking at it too you can see
how maybe one of them didn't understand
that and didn't see that but I'm not
trying to get back into that my big
question is do you know about DCF
constituent relations I absolutely do I
know about child advocacy I know about
the busman I know about all of those
people and none of them have been
helpful for me have you given them a
rundown of where you believe that they
didn't follow your policies I've given
them a right yes numerous times I've
spoken for with um KRON at the child
advocacy more than one time I spoken
with Jennifer I think her name is at the
constituent more than one time they they
they listen to me on the phone for over
an hour each of them each time that I
spoke to them and they were really
concerned this is this was their concern
for me their concern is that my parental
rights are going to be terminated
because I refuse to comply with dcyf
because that's where I'm at I'm not
complying with anything that they want
me to do I'm not submitting to anything
that they want me to do because they
should not have my children to begin
with now as I I have had yes dealings
with with DCS in past my rights were
terminated to three of my children 16
years ago 16 years ago because I didn't
have suitable housing my rights were
terminated because I didn't have
suitable housing 16 years
ago there's a lot of people who don't
have suitable hous there's a lot of
homeless people out there we're going to
start taking people's children because
they don't have they don't have an
apartment at the time or a certain place
to live with their children not
everybody has the means to be able to to
live in a luxurious big five-bedroom
house you know what I mean but I always
always did the best of my kids were
always loved and and knew you know knew
knew who their mom was and that I did
the best that I could at the time with
what I had every time so and can I ask
another question to you have your adult
sons who have Apartments um if if I'm
not going to ask you whether or not they
wanted your son to be in there because
that's not my business and it's not
something that I want to ask and put out
there on the Internet or anything like
that with the recordings what I want to
ask is if DCF was helpful if the request
was made for them to have a kinship
guard kinship care for them to be placed
with those those brothers that was that
was actually done with my oldest 29y old
um they did the home study for to have
my children go with them and they were
they found they did not approve for them
to go with my 29-year-old son whom I
raised by the way with me never was in
foster care or none of that he was only
his whole life um because because he
they didn't feel that he could set
appropriate
boundaries with me meaning meaning not
have allow me around the children or
whatever said appropriate they didn't
think that he could set appropriate
boundaries so and boundaries against me
the boundaries were as as a followup I
find it concerning that if the removal
was for not having suitable housing that
that if that is the reason for the expar
that they're not letting you speak with
I with this um I definitely would be
interested in talking with you more
about this it seems like you've tried to
go through some of these processes and
tried to talk to the right people but
you've ended up with dead ends yes I've
done I've done a lot a lot of that and
and I want to point out also that the
main the main reason I believe that this
was this is um happened was because what
like the the situation with City Welfare
Manchester City Welfare is that I was I
was um I was I was bringing making a lot
of noise I was speaking at the uh
mayor's meetings as mayor Al men public
meetings I was um I was I was putting it
online all of this because they are
because even right now they they're
charging people who are in the financial
hardship for shelter reimbursement in
the law RSA 16520 B says that they can
be reimbursed after they have assisted
you not during not while not in the
meantime after they've assisted you they
can they can you know request shelter
reimbursement unless it places you in a
financial hardship now who is in a
homeless shelter and not considered to
be in a financial
hardship so she was telling me to my
face that I was not in a financial
hardship the lady I said Heather Moran
the one that called on me
and I didn't know how to like I couldn't
understand why that was hard to respond
to yes because I'm like yes like what
and I get crazy I apologize for
representative love having to leave for
his other meeting I think we may have
some other people that are having the
same I don't know if anybody else had
any
questions um yeah so so that was that
that was the main reason behind even her
even her suspending me for the 14 days
she's saying that I couldn't account for
$1,300 she had the email email in her in
her email sitting me accounting for the
$1,300 that she was talking about so she
didn't have to suspend me but she did
anyways and she and the and the sick
part is is that they had an empty room
because they contract four of the rooms
from family transition they contract
four of those rooms and they had an
empty room and she was denying me and my
children's shelter because I couldn't
account for $1,300 that was sitting in
her
email so that's why you know she called
insisted and called again like
oh she just got arrested oh she like
what like what what are you reporting DC
of my my life for like that's none of
the business you know what I mean so
that's that's why I believe even more so
you know that this this this happened to
me not necessarily because I was being
neglectful because I was not being
neglectful I was doing I was doing
whatever I could for my children and the
police told me that I could sleep in my
car so if if it's not against the law
for the and the police told me that I
could sleep in my car then what is the
problem here it was warm outside it was
summertime if I pitched my Somewhere
That's My Prerogative as their
mother but the courts doesn't seem to
think so that I got to tell them my
business where I'm going to be sleeping
otherwise you remove my children from
me this none of this none of this is
okay none of this makes sense and and
what I know is that they do this to
people on a daily basis and that's why
I'm more I'm more willing and I know
it's at risk I know it's at risk here
it's already happened to me but
I'm willing to to I'm willing to take
that sa make that sacrifice if it's
going to if it's going to stop these
people from doing what they're doing to
Al to my people because there's people
from my community that's going through
this it's people from from my life's
experiences that are going through this
and I have no resolve and I have no
Solutions and just get and then these
people just continue to lie on them on
us and get away with it so I'm willing
to do that like like I know I don't
think there's really many people out
there that would be willing to do that I
don't I I can't think of any that's how
far I'm willing to go like Isaac brought
his son up to the mountain I'm willing
to just just to not comply just to show
how how how what it is that's going on
here because like I said it's bigger
than me and my children this is bigger
than me and my children because as I
said 16 years ago they terminated my
parental rights at that time I did have
substance abuse issues I went to prison
I got clean I was clean for 5 years I
remained clean not once testing dirty
having random drug screens for 5 years
when I had my trial to for my children I
was not even the same person anymore I
did everything that they wanted me to do
I complied with everything and I even
put some more stuff on my own that I was
not required just to go above and beyond
to prove that I deserved my own children
just to lose so if I'm going to lose
this time I'm going to lose at my terms
not at their terms by complying and
losing
anyways because now my children are
grown they're 19 20 and 21 years old
and and and they didn't have didn't have
me and and I just recently got in
contact with one with my daughters and
and just this past weekend my my
29-year-old oldest son and my
20-year-old daughter reunited for the
first time since since they were taken
over 16 years ago 16 years ago when my
rights were terminated it was over when
she was four years old she's 20 now she
doesn't even remember him and the same
thing with my mom and these are the
things that people don't when when they
take our children and terminate our
rights and do that that they those
things are not even considered they're
not even thought about what the the the
harm and the that the the the trauma and
the Damage that you caus these children
lifelong thinking that whatever you know
whatever was in their reports that I did
this that I left them alone to go party
that I that I didn't take care of them
things that were not factual that are
not true and I believe that they have
come back in my life right now at the
worst point that I could possibly be in
my life to see this play out because I'm
not even going to have to explain to
them or show to them or prove to them
that I did everything that I possibly
could to get them back and I
lost and they're going to see that
they're going to see all of this play
out because my my daughter watches most
of the most of the stuff that I put out
and and the things that I that I do the
speaking and that I do podcasts that
I've been on because I've been speaking
about this non-stop Non-Stop and the
thing is is that what keeps me going are
the people that I don't even know that
send me messages in my inbox and and
encourage me and say yeah this happened
to me too like it's it's it's mind
boggling the amount of people that I've
come across just by that telling me same
like different similar stories some
worse some some the same some not as bad
nonetheless same stories I have a um so
miss GL yes you are an amazing Fighter
for your kids but the strongest thing
that stands out to me right here your
relationship with your adult
kids that that shows me how much you
care it shows me a lot of pure heart um
with what we are working with and trying
to understand I I think one of the
things that we need to make sure is that
the reports to constituent relations are
processed in a way where they can see if
they're hearing these reports from you
and from other parents about where
they're not following policies we need
to find out where that goes and how it's
processed and how it's handled because
if that just sort of comes into an inbox
and and nothing really gets reviewed
once and nothing much happens that
doesn't help to protect other families
or the same families when they come back
so that's one of those things that I
will look into before next week um I do
know rep representative Weber had had to
leave for another meeting um and I'm not
sure how many more of us um with that
I quite frankly my empathy and
compassion for everything that's already
happened to you I already have the
things that I need to focus on with that
um I'm happy to listen to more but I
think that right now I see moving
forward trying to make sure that we get
those reports is probably the most
important thing to keep this from
happening from other families that's
that's my um ultimate
ultimately ultimately what I'm hoping
for is that we see that because the fact
of the matter is that DCF receives money
different from from the Social Security
from title
4E and was 42e 4E 42 one of those um and
they receive
incentives all kinds of incentives you
could possib any you could possibly
think of they get paid for so they have
incentives for removing people's
children they don't have incentives for
keeping the children at home or for
finding the resources because all they
would have had to done is help me with
some housing not remove my children
that's not in their best interest and
that's the part that like we're
operating under what's in the best
interest of the children and in most
cases that I have heard experienc or
been that's been shared with me nothing
has been in their best interest 29 kids
died at their hands who were taken from
their parents for their best interest
and they ended up dying in DCF custody
20 24 and 29 the year before that and
having a parent who will fight for you
is one of those things that's pretty
strong informational for a child to know
that their parent cares enough to fight
for them um so thank you for fighting
for your kids I know as we move forward
with this I don't know how else what
else you know I mean I don't know how
not to do that well there's parents who
wouldn't there's parents who don't fight
for their kids so that makes you really
really special that you do even with
everything that you've gone through so
thank you thank you um I just wanted to
I don't know if you're aware you're
probably aware but there is also a a
children's Bill of Rights you know that
they're supposed to be presented at a
certain age that they have to follow for
the children's Bill of Rights while
they're in foster care which includes
parent visits with friend with parents
includes that the parents be involved in
all the you know anything the decisions
that are being made about them blah they
blah ongoing and obviously that's not
being followed either
um and um and I just also I just wanted
to reference I don't know if you have if
anyone has told you all about the the
recent report that ACLU released it's
called if I wasn't poor I wouldn't be
unfit and like that that shows the
numbers you know the the statistics the
all of the the um disproportionate it's
pretty much disproportionate for us as
it is for people that go to prison you
know black minorities and lowincome
social economic scale um so it's like
140 or 64 page report this
so this not it's not like it's just a
new Hamp this is like across the country
but just to to has a lot of information
in there that could be useful that you
will see that these things are are
really happening in is that more recent
than the last six months I believe it's
within the last six months this is when
I came across it because um I believe I
distributed one um or at least the link
to it with everybody um with one of
those talking about the dis
disproportionate impact on that yeah it
was was it called um if I wasn't poor I
wouldn't be unfit um it rings a bell um
that may be one and so I will look to
that because that is that is one of the
issues um just to make sure that make
sure that people aren't mixing the
different issues together right right
and that's why you took my children for
being homeless and now you want to add
stipulations and uh um want me to submit
to drug test want me to have therapy I
already do therapy on my own but you
don't have to tell me to do therapy
based on what based on my history now
you want to use my history again me I've
been clean since 2016 when I got on
methodone and I got off methodone in
2017 and I've been in recovery ever
since and you want to bring up my past
and you want to use this when this has
nothing to do with any of that that
those are the kinds of things that they
parents so one of the things that you
would like to see is to see in the
policy is that somebody who's resolved
their past they're not using that
against them I do know that I've loved
ones that have had heroin issues and
there's always that Rel relapse
opportunity right so obviously there's
some to that too just because but just
because someone uses drugs doesn't make
them a bad parent that's where the
resources need to come in and they
actually need to address the issue and
not make the issue more make it more
trauma make it harder on the people
because like you said some parents don't
fight some parents don't have enough of
that fight left in them once you remove
their children they they've lost all
their hope you know what I mean because
they know fighting a system like this
there's really no hope yes you know what
I mean yes um so I think that that
looking to making sure that somebody's
pass that they've moved they've built
themselves up from moved on from and
moved past and probably become a
stronger person because of um that
that's not something that's separating
somebody from their family because a
role model who can uh break an addiction
like that and stay clean especially when
facing challenges right right that's a
role model it's and and it's not always
the easiest thing to do either you know
and the things like this the stressors
that they add on to to my if I if I were
not if I were not so grounded in my
faith number one my faith in God because
that's the only really the thing that
keeps me going having hope is because I
know that I know God is behind me and
forness of that and obviously you know
the length of time that I've had yeah
the enemy would still try like to have
one think like just go just go out and
get and get messed up I dealing with
something like this yeah absolutely but
thank God pray that I'm that I was not
you know I mean that I did not fall
victim to that and that I would did not
end up that didn't not end up happening
to me but it could have very well
happened you know what I mean and it
would been unnecessary and it would have
been uncalled for and all that just as
as a result of these agencies getting
away and operating however they want
because that's basically what they're
doing so the last thing I just wanted to
play is just a couple of minutes of the
of the of my son no I'm sorry that that
one if we get to you recording something
where then it's not recorded my son
recorded he's 14 years old he recorded
dcyf supervisor telling him that they
don't want him this is plenty relevant
and this is what happens in the in these
cases and you know why you guys don't
believe that's why they don't believe
them even having evidence like this
seeing people don't want to hear it they
want to turn their face to it or their
ears to it and not and not actually
acknowledge that these things are happen
son what I'm trying to do isn't to bury
this or anything like that once you're
getting into the fact that he recorded
it as one party not AUD not you um and I
turned off your mic so you can turn it
back on um I just don't want you to get
into a situation I don't care I'm
willing to sacrifice anything that I got
to sacrifice but go to jail get arrested
I don't care as long as the people are
held responsible for what the part that
they play and and they're held
accountable too I'm not the only ones
that should be held that should be uh
the law should be enforced on they have
to follow the law too they have to
follow things too and they're not so I'm
willing to do whatever I got to do like
I said I I don't really it don't matter
much to me I just want what's supposed
to happen to be
thank
you and um I did give Miss Glenn a lot
more time because we've seen you before
and I wanted to make sure that she had a
chance to share with us what was going
on I am going to ask you to keep it more
limited because I we're going to lose
even more people to our next commitments
and I apologize for that um I wasn't
sure that people were going to come and
when we first started off and started
talking about that we just had
representative kushman we didn't have
you here so I wasn't able to manage our
schedule in order to accommodate that so
I'll keep you brief sir and give us your
name again hello my name is Donald
Gilbert um so yeah so yes I'm definitely
keep it uh brief here um one thing that
I do want to point out is I was not
informed about this until 10 o'clock
last night so I don't know if it made it
on the calendar before yesterday but
somebody informed me yesterday and it
seems that that notification went on
about 5:00 yesterday um so with that the
it went on the house calendar which went
out a week ago there was a notification
sent out um there's not there's no way
to the technology requirements to have
anybody interested we know about a
calendar notice before the calendar just
would be too much to do but it was in
the house calendar understandable yeah
so just on the actual House website
where it lists everything it was not on
there it might have been in like the one
that gets sent out to all of the house
but it wasn't on the published you know
this body's meeting on this day this day
um I think with that you may have been
looking at the house meeting schedule
which is supposed to be done as a
convenience to everybody the official
record is the calendar the one that's
been published um since long before I
was born um I've also run into the same
challenge of just technology not having
it on the house meeting schedule so sure
especially when you're looking for this
just if you're on Twitter or X I'm
dating myself if you're on X sign up to
the New Hampshire um the house clerk
okay because the house clerk will
publish the new calendar link every time
it's out with a shortened one so that
you can do that and check and look and
see if the Committees that you're
interested in our meeting sure thing so
I'm going to make this probably a little
bit of Rapid Fire here we're going to
touch back on what Giselle just
testified about and indicate that so you
heard earlier this year about some of
the background of myself and
whatnot it wasn't till that that mother
was going to be homeless that they took
the children from the
home down in Manchester for my
children's
siblings again just to recap DCF was
having the children in the home for two
years in violation of criminal bail
conditions for seven counts of child
pornography and in violation of 169c
protective orders that were specific to
that that individual specific to those
children and the court was upholding no
contact orders DCF refused to follow
those no contact
orders we don't know it'd be nice for
DCF to let people know but it's clear um
so may if I since you're going to be
rapid fire I'm going to interrupt you to
ask questions did you report that
through the constituent relations and
the others when they were in violation
of that so just yeah I guess we can
recap there I have regular
Communications with the new director uh
Marine unim I have regular connections
with the uh constituent relations
supervisor uh and obviously the ab
budsman office and the office of the
child advocate and we collaboratively
approach different things but um as
you'll hear here later on the office of
the child advocate and some of these
even the internal Administration is
getting shut down from the local office
administration as to what's going on at
the local
offices um but that's something
unrelated to this I'm the reason I'm
asking is because if this may this may
be one of those areas I know we've seen
some of it before but we didn't we
weren't necessarily asking if people
were reporting it through those
processes throughout yes so yeah so I
mean just myself included you know
obviously I've seen it with that
situation with my own children's
siblings with what Griselle has gone
through um you know I think it's
horrific that we're going to go ahead
and leave the children in the home you
know with all of that going on but now
that they're facing homelessness oh
that's when we go ahead oop sorry that's
when we go ahead and remove the children
that you know a little disheartening
there um and I know of several other
cases where the children have been
removed because the parents were
homeless um up in the Lakes Region um I
deal with I'm at Isaiah's calf quite
frequently um and engage with a lot of
the and again I understand a lot of the
individuals do have substance abuse
backgrounds but the rebuttal of
presumption of harm was
uh repealed at the time over that it
just went it just barely went back into
effect you know just in the last couple
of months or so so under the rebuttable
presumption of harm that wasn't there
before so you can't use somebody's drug
addiction against them you can't use
somebody's homelessness against them if
the child's living in a tent as long as
they are psychologically in physically
well you're they're entitled to be in
that tent you know unfortunately you
know that's what the law is I mean
fortunate enough for the parents but you
know as the parents are actually caring
for and if the schools are not reporting
neglect or abuse and medical providers
are not reporting NE neglect and abuse
and things are being taken care of
you're not allowed to take that child
from that tent it doesn't matter I mean
they could be on the the street corner
you know you're supposed to be supplying
them with the services the services are
there the money is there Supply the
services we won't get into you know all
of that moving on though from that one
of the big issues right now that I think
everywhere is seeing it was brought
forth to the oversight Commission
on children services last month which
obviously meets again
tomorrow and Office of the child
advocate testified indicating that DCF
has been hiding records and forging
records to the office of the child
advocate and the Attorney General's
office um and you can obviously speak to
any of those members or OCA and get that
testimony from them directly um I know
case specific
I have a supervisor who's no longer a
supervisor that went ahead and gave me
an email documentation certifying that
Administration within dcyf was
requesting the local office to not
record documents and to not record
interactions at least for my specific
case I don't know how much and the
timeline on that is kind of impeccable
if you go back to right about uh I think
it was like I don't remember what time
in July but there was a lawsuit that was
filed against the state and the governor
and in August it was before the
legislative performance audit committee
it was brought up in there where they
decided that they were not going to
continue to investigate or bring forth
subpoenas against some of these things
because the fa these specific topics
are there's a federal lawsuit pending
against the governor and the state for
these
issues um so it kind of Falls in line of
everybody shutting down at this point
and refusing to I have not had any
engagement with my cpsw since
July so because they refuse to engage um
in a way that can be recorded and
documented um we don't know if that's
Direction it assuming that it's not
direction from the Attorney General's
office but obviously the Attorney
General's office is the one that has to
represent the state in defending this
lawsuit as well so it's a very hard
predicament for the Attorney General's
office to criminally investigate the
department while also defending the
department from these Federal
lawsuits you know something has to give
and change here so that the transparency
can open up and things can be held
accountable so that we we're not just
covering it
up um I I don't know exactly how we do
that but you know some members have
indicated one way is to get the division
out from underneath the scope of thhs
and have them assign their own defending
attorneys and whatnot and have a
complete beer you know Departments of
children
services focusing on children's services
providing and upholding their policies
and their laws that's one of the biggest
things is the policies and laws are in
place they don't follow them you know
you know so again trying to keep it less
case specific but case specific my child
is in an unlicensed foster home
currently and so they've indicated well
they've permitted the foster home it
took nine months for them to permit this
foster home well if you look at the
definition of permit under HC uh HC 644
six the definition is means of temporary
authorization to operate a family foster
home uh sorry foster home yeah as
defined as RSA
170e
252a for a period not to exceed 6 months
well if you go to 170 uh e
252a that's for licensing Child Care
institutions of caring for 12 or more
children there is no permitting process
to individually license a single-body
person and they're not following their
own
things did you have a question um with
that there is certain Foster Family
approval there may be some difference in
how the language is there I was involved
in approving some of those rules around
Foster families but Foster families do
the foster homes do go through um what I
would view as a inspection and
permitting process even if the terms
aren't that which are probably somewhere
near in the rules near where you find
that found that first one in
6446 but they're diff those honestly
sometimes those rules are difficult
enough for the drafting attorneys within
the different departments to know each
of them that I'm not going to expect you
to find everyone no so uh you're
actually bringing up some really really
good points about the lack of resource
recourse for following laws rules and
policy in the conflict um with the
attorney general both um defending the
government and investigating the
government um also I think you brought
up the idea that there's really nowhere
for whistleblowers to go um that's
another area that I think is probably
very important um a as we look at this
that's actually something that refers to
other departments and other parts of the
state too that might benefit from The
Whistleblower one um looking at this
there's only so many things that people
can focus on at one time um my question
at this this point taking this
information and some others is whether
legislators should be looking at that
inherent conflict and how we would
address that while protecting
whistleblowers because there's a good
chance that some of the things that have
happened if we had had whistleblowers
would have changed
um yeah I can tell you right now there
there's many whistleblowers and
obviously a lot of them try to stay
protected at this point because they are
state employees themselves and they
don't want to be you know
a lot of the whistleblowers over the
years have been terminated wrongfully
and then sued the state for wrongful
termination because they were
whistleblowing these problems you know
so there there's still plenty of
whistleblowers within the system uh you
know it's very well known and it's going
to continue and you know but the the
issue is is there's no real recourse you
know under the current mechanisms of how
the structure of DHHS is you know
because if you go ahead and terminate
these employees well then for cause then
you're admitting to the
problem you know and that that's the
biggest thing and they don't want to
admit to their wrongdoings because then
you have a $37 million lawsuit that gets
handed down and you know and that $37
million could have helped a lot of fames
that
correct exactly but but in the meantime
you have so will use a general synopsis
of a a case of a child in Manchester
very high-profile case um those case
workers are over most of these other
cases that are also seeing lawsuits and
the ones that are still they're still
employed doing the same thing for many
other cases putting these children at
risk Dennis V sorry no names yep a
another high-profile case in Lone where
the you know the grandmother was just
charged over the summer same exact thing
those are the same case works the same
case workers over the Manchester one are
the same case workers over the lonia one
they just moved them from one office to
the
next so
it's very interesting I mean it it takes
a very proactive person to get anything
done and even then you know they Tred to
shut down I've gone through seven
different attorneys I've ended up um you
know terminating seven of their
attorneys over the last four
years um and multiple supervisors and
case workers have been terminated
because of for cause
reasons but it it's coming from the top
and it's trickling down and the people
at the bottom are the ones taking the
blame for the actions of the people at
the top you know we don't know exactly
who we have a good idea but it
you know if people aren't coming to the
table you know and obviously the office
of the child advocate has a good idea
and you know they've brought it Forward
they brought it forward to the oversight
commission last month and said you know
we know who these people are but DHHS is
not taking them out of play and they're
you know telling people to you know
redact that you know the office of the
child Havoc has subpoena powers and and
yet these administrators are redacting
information from these oversight AG
genes
so we I'm sure we'll hear more tomorrow
at the next session but thank you for
your
time yes thank you but so I think that's
about it for today I think that gives
you a general synopsis of kind of what's
been going on at least over the last six
months um and why some of this push back
and whatnot you might be you know
everywhere might be seeing on certain
things is it is perceived anyways from
the conversations that I've had with
many different individuals that are
players at B is because of this Federal
filed um thank you thank you that um
you're always very insightful when you
come up and it's become so much more
powerful after removing the names from
your testimony because we can focus on
the facts correct instead of the names
so thank you I would ask more questions
but I feel like you've given given me a
lot to go on um I I do feel like if
there was some process to hold the
government accountable and protect
whistleblowers that likely would both
protect children and protect families
exactly so yes definitely um and that's
one of the biggest things and actually
uh recently I had you know the current
administrator that's over the case tell
me Well if a parent's releasing the case
then they should be in jail because DCF
was breaching confidentiality and Court
had upheld for them not to be breaching
this confidentiality and so we went a
little TI tip fortat with the laws and
you know my attorney and I went ahead
and shared the exact law where it does
allow for parents now to go ahead and
release information so long as the
child's name is redacted under 170
G and you know needless to say the
division you know defaulted to saying
yes you know we apologize we are you
know XYZ but um I just to touch back on
the foster care thing so under the
administrative rules there's nothing
under statue in the definition or statue
there is but because the administrative
rules are more restrictive DHHS and DCF
is supposed to follow the administrative
rules as the most restrictive now
obviously they can go ahead and change
those administrative rules but they have
not done so yet so when they go ahead
and change them to make them less
restrictive as as the legislative has
done under RSA
170 then there's a permitting process
for individuals but currently under the
more restrictive admin code there is not
and we've had my legal team of many
attorneys go ahead and oversee this and
you know address that so there is in the
RSA so if you if you're in your legal
team found areas with that um I I'll
speak to you after on this sure not a
problem thank you all already thank you
thank
you representative
kushman thank you members of the
committee representative Leah kushman
from
where um so just from listening um to
what was said up until now um I just
have a few closing thoughts um so as far
as the cend assist letter um that it was
not written in legal jargon
it was literally said I am asking you to
immediately cease and assist because
from the testimony that I received it's
my belief based on it that there are
deprivation of Rights occurring and it
needs to stop now and so we can figure
it out and at the end of the email it
said let's work together to make this
right I mean I think that stating that
that's the reason that we can't get DCF
in here um is I won't apply motive um
but I think it's wrong um I've sent
similar emails about other issues I sent
one to D DHHS um childcare licensing um
division before because they were Den
they were not um enforcing the
requirement that dayc carees accept Rel
religious exemptions um I've sent them
to you know it's just an email I'm I'm
Duty Bound by my oath to call out
something wrong when I see it and say
hey this needs to be fixed can you tell
me how we can fix this
um so it was a long email but so with
that question um I I do know that with
those other ones that you referen those
were very specific in the requests um
and they were very effective in moving
forward because there was a gap that was
identified was the season um did you
feel that the seasoned assist on dcyf
was as narrowly drafted I do um it
basically it said you can continue to do
the assessments but you can't be having
internal tribunals and if you're you're
alleging abuse and neglect it needs to
be it needs to be um put into the court
where people have access to a trial by
jury um as guaranteed by the
Constitution and I
mean you know I I don't think it can get
much more specific than that but so I'm
but I just wanted to state that that I I
even said I'm asking I implore I did not
say I demand there were no demands made
made it was here are problems I see I
think we can't do this anymore please
stop now let's figure out how to fix it
so that it's in line with
Constitution um so that that's our job
um as the committee Char as for the
committee charge legislation doesn't
only include bills um it's any action by
the legislature including issuing
subpoenas warrants holding in contempt
for failing to appear um and comply and
for obstructing our work um even issu
punishments the house has that Authority
per the Constitution um and that can go
into the report as recommendations that
we do that going forward with these
people who are not complying with
subpoenas um with the OCA and the AG um
in order to get DCF in here there is
already a process anyone saying there
isn't I won't apply motive um but the
Constitution and parliamentary law give
the legislature the ability to subpoena
Witnesses um in New Hampshire it needs a
vote of the whole house uh I that's why
my attempt to form a committee that had
subpoena power was brought to the floor
um so that it would be just the
committee because that's how it is under
Masons and in a lot of other states and
in Congress the committee itself can
issue subpoenas so it doesn't have to go
before the whole house um and that that
gives us narrow power for the subject
matter experts who are working on the
issues um and so and it kind of
insulates it from broader political um
interplace um so the
so maybe recommending in the report that
the next committee have that power um or
recommending that there be a change to
house rules to give those types of
committees subpoena power if they don't
comply like they haven't with the OCA
the house can issue a warrant given to
the sheriff um which is then served and
the person is brought to the house the
house can then hold them and punish them
it's in the
Constitution um if you look at Mason's
section
802 um summon subpoenas and warrants a
legislative body or committee when
within the scope of his authority to
conduct a uh investigation May summon
and examine Witnesses and require
production and examination of books
records and papers when a committee is
authorized The subpoena Witnesses the
chair of the committee in conjunction
with its councel May select the names
and number of witnesses for attention at
each session and the chair May sign the
summons to each witness subpoena should
not be issued in blank so it just has to
be specific uh when a witness lawfully
summon refuses to appear a warrant may
be issued to compel the witness's
attendance no affidavit charging
contempt need be filed for the house to
authorize to issue its warrant to arrest
a contous person who refuses to testify
before one of its committees the written
report of the committee is sufficient
Authority for the issuance of the
warrant a person disobeying a subpoena
of a legislative committee may be
apprehended and brought before the
committee by a sheriff under a warrant
issued to the sheriff and either
prosecuted for misdemeanor under a
statute for failure to to obey a
subpoena which we don't have or punished
for contempt by the legislature but that
person cannot be punished by the
Judiciary for
contempt um the
Constitution gives more um illumination
to that power the house shall have
authority to punish by imprisonment
every person who shall be guilty of
disrespect to the house in its Presence
by any disorderly or contemptuous
Behavior or by or by obstructing its
deliberations um or in disturbing any
one of the officers in exe execution of
any order of procedure of the house or
in rescuing any person arrested by order
of the house knowing them to be such so
like it's alluding there that we have
that ability it's not really an arrest
like where you um like where the
executive branch would um under law
enforcement arrest somebody the warrants
that uh A legislature issues are are
strictly to force the appearance of
someone who is a subpoena and and
refused to comply with the subpoena and
then the the sergeant of AR at arms are
constables they have all of the um
Authority that a constable has and
including detaining an individual and
then the house can make a resolution um
right then to apply a punishment on its
own it doesn't need the Senate doesn't
it doesn't um act it's not acted upon
like a bill um they can say the
punishment is this person stays chained
to the the chair you know in the
speaker's office for the duration of the
day or the house hereby finds you in
contempt of the the house the you know
New Hampshire house and it's a Scarlet
Letter for forever um a fine is even
less than that so I think that there's
case law that that states um it's a
lesser punishment so it's also um
applicable and can be issued
um because it's lesser than imprisonment
there's other case uh other crimes that
have um been prosecuted as such in
courts of law but I I think we have the
authority to
punish um to go get somebody and force
them to appear and force them to to
bring their documents um I think that a
lot of people just don't know um so the
uh in our house yeah it has to all the
in the house rules number six it says
all warrants subpoenas and other
processes issued by the house shall be
signed by the speaker attested to by the
clerk so we we have it on our rules it's
acknowledged there we do have warrant
power um as for representative Weber's
comment she can say that she doesn't
agree that cases need to go before a
trial by jury um but I think it's
antithetical to the O oath and it's in
conflict with the Constitution and
recent um uh Supreme Court um rulings
the punishment before being um having a
finding in an administrative tribunal or
in the Family Court they're already
being punished they're already having
their children removed from them um it
would be appropriate if they were
arrested for an allegation of a crime
and then were in jail or had bail
conditions where they couldn't have
access to the child until their their
due process can be um you know carried
out but before you make a finding you're
you're already issuing severe punishment
to these people for three four five six
months before they even have their
dispositional a judicatory hearing um in
the family court or their um their
internal Tri tribunals where the parents
aren't even given notice to appear and
they just receive the finding in the
mail that's all sidest stepping to due
process so um it's a civil death pen
penalty essentially and um I I implore
you all to read SEC versus daresi it was
about the SEC but it's similar it's an
administrative tribunal where the state
is basically the agency is a is is a is
a judge in its own case um and that's
unlawful and basically the the finding
was that if if at the time of the
founding a a similar cause of action um
came with a right to a trial by jury you
can't just change its name and its venue
and change the rules around it and
deprive constitutional due process and
say that you don't get a trial by jury
um so child abuse child abuse is a crime
neglect is a crime harm of children is a
crime it needs to be prosecuted by law
enforcement heard in an open trial in a
real Court um of law that ensures no
arbitrary decision- making that we keep
hearing constantly happens in family
court and and tribunals in DCF and with
the substantive due process requirements
um with DCF interacting before it ever
goes to to court um and it needs to have
no conflicts of interests and we've
heard that the the federal incentives
present a conflict of interests if it
doesn't rise to the level of a crime
then the government has no authority to
be interfering um with consent they can
provide voluntary services but that's it
they should be giving people family
therapy they should be giving people
parenting classes I think that's a
legitimate role for DCF I don't think
that criminal quasi criminal quasi civil
investigations without due process is
appropriate for them um there's no
significant difference between the
ongoing litigation cases involving YDC
and dcyf which expose the problematic
practices of warehousing children and
tearing families apart for profit per
government program funding and the
actions of the Bureau for child support
services and family court which
similarly practice separating families
and creating a pipeline of children for
profit profit the business model
practice has seven commonalities the age
of the child Financial projections
protraction me methods ways to make the
case carry on because it creates more
money artificial story creation
deflecting responsibility onto targeted
families and children void of concern
and care for the children and families
and no intent to stop and avoiding
account
accountability all of those are are
common in all three of those Arenas um
and their patterns it was said that
there were no patterns to recognize I
think there's tons of patterns that that
have been brought that we can recognize
so I I'll finish with um recommendations
for
legislation um number one how about body
cameras for social workers subject to
exculpatory evidence we hear a lot of
hearsay um that's entered upon the court
and and parents say that it was a lie
and there's never any um followup for
perjury even when it's proven that it
was was a lie and also exemption from
wiretapping laws for members of the
public recording government servants um
I believe constitutionally that's
already the case you have a right to to
record government servants um fixed
language in the statute that was
inserted with SP 417 from this year that
creates a litmus teest for Parental
Fitness for parents not charged with
abuse most of the the cases um for
termination of parental rights don't
have an an accompanying criminal charge
of abuse so that's of those parents and
it's the parents who aren't even alleged
to have abused in those administrative
courts either um the the fitness test
has a bunch of vague requirements um you
know and and some of it violates the Ada
untreated mental illness I mean that's
that's violating the Americans for
Disabilities Act and what's untreated if
they take St John's wart is that
untreated instead of an SSRI you know um
I think that there's just a lot of room
for for uh a narrative to be created and
um orders to be issued that uh you know
is based on someone's opinion and it's
not it's not uh objective um a part of
that is also that a parent compliance
with dcyf is weighed for or against them
in maintaining their children and with
over $5 million in lawsuits every year
for maladministration for child deaths
for all kinds of rights violations by
this um agency it's not a wonder why
parents don't want to comply with them
and don't want to engage with them um so
I think that needs to be struck but
aside from that you can remove all of
these problems if we removed DCF from
the child abuse and neglect
investigation side of things and
relegate it to placing children with no
family and providing services such as
family therapy and parenting classes
voluntarily child abuse investigations
back into the hands of law enforcement
like it was um until the 1970s that
would end here say evidence Anonymous
reporting that can be weaponized it
removes the ability to um that that uh
Anonymous reporting removes the ability
to face your accuser and cross-examine
Witnesses who assert the charges uh
allegations against you
um it it it would restore due process in
these cases easily swiftly put it in
courts of law they have to follow
um consistent Rules of Evidence and the
jury finds the facts not just a judge
and you know we've heard that there's
seems to be rubber stamping going on a
jury's not going to rubber stamp
anything you know that that's why we
have a trials by jury because it's
considered the best way to ensure a fair
process right where jurries find the
facts um ensure that all funding for
dcyf and prosecution of abuse and
neglect cases is from the state budget
and not federal programs that create
conflicts and that prosecution occurs in
courts of law not quasi criminal quasi
civil quasi Equity courts that are
Guided by an amalgamation of statutes
that sidestep Constitution will due
process and thereby you can eliminate
any um arbitrary application of law
amend house rules to give subpoena power
and warrant power to the Committees to
and inform legislator legislators of
that power give the Committees more
direct oversight and enforcement power
right now the whole house has it we have
it to say we don't is not true and then
bills of address
the clerk has mentioned uh to me that
state employees for state employees the
equivalent of an impeachment in the
house is a bill of address I don't know
much about that process um but I think
it's something that needs to be examined
more because there are people named in
numerous lawsuits and complaints who are
still sitting in their positions and
able to harm Children and Families
hiding records forging records let's
file bills of address um and as far as
whistleblowers uh there's already laws
for that to protect
them so if other branches are failing to
protect them or failing to give them
standing like we saw with ER Anna
carrian um in their whistleblower cases
the legislature needs to take the
investigator role we have broad powers
to investigate um as I've described with
enforcement for non-compliance and all
of that so thank you very much for
letting me lay that all up thank you
very much that was very helpful it was
very helpful
send
us yes thank you yep thank you thank you
helpful thank you and with that um I
will close this meeting I will be in
touch with everybody for scheduling the
next one I'm hoping to have more
progress on the separation of dcyf um
before scheduling because I think that
should help with um even some of the
ideas that representative kushman had
brought forth um I think are integral to
the idea making sure that it has its
proper role so and I thank everybody for
their attendance and the meeting is
closed